in any Hollywood movie if someone has to
dial a phone number it will start
bye-bye and the reason for that not only
is it American tradition but the five
five five zero block is blocked out
across America for dramatic numbers so
all numbers that start five five five
zero with a couple of rare exceptions
will never get through now they have but
a couple of movies that have tried to
use other numbers because hearing five
five five doesn't take you out the
actionable and rooks Almighty who
managed to spark whole load of people
trying to call God when his number was
flashed up on screen and now of course
at slightly worse in America because the
caller doesn't just pay for the phone
call to a cell phone the person with the
cell phone pays as well so suddenly
someone was getting twenty or thirty
calls an hour and all they were asking
for was God but you might not know
though is that Britain also has numbers
like that in one of the few good
decisions are off come the regulator's
ever made about phone numbers there are
a few blocks marked out in London
it's otro 7 9 4 6 are the several blocks
and cities across Britain and for rural
areas an entire area tone oh one six
three two that is guaranteed never to
connect there's a mobile phone number to
Oh double seven double oh nine that
whole block will never ever get its root
or anything and at the exchange level
well it just cuts you off straight away
if you're on a cell phone you'll never
get through and if you're on one of
these an old-fashioned blind line you
won't even get halfway through dialing
it before you get tough